[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى الشيخ
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعله اخرى
الجوي في سبب خلل لم تتضح طبيعته تماما
تدريجيا حركه الطيران داخليا وخارجيا
الاقلاعا وهبوطا
وايضا مشهد ياتينا مباشره من كياف
اوكرانيا تقول ان اللفوانيه تعهدت بمدها
بانظمه دفاع جوي في وقت التقى فيه زنسكي
نظريه اللثواني والبولندي في مدينه الفيفا
الاوكرانيه
الى كابول التي تشهد تفجيرا انتحاريا اخر
بالقرب من وزاره الخارجيه ذهب ضحيته اكثر
من 20 قتيلا وجرح ما لا يقل عن اربعه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
روسيا تدفع بالقياده العليا لقوتها
المسلحه الى الساحه المعركه رئيس الاركان
يتولى قياده قوه بلاده في اوكرانيا منشيه
فاجنر تعلن ان السيطره وحدها على سوليدار
والكريم لن يدعو للتريث قبل اي اعلان
بينما تنفيذ
رئيس الوزراء اليابانيه يستبق زيارته
للولايات المتحده بالتحذير من تكرار
السيناريو والاوكراني في اسيا ويوقعوا في
لندن اتفاقيه الدفاع المشترك مع بريطانيا
تسمح بتبادل نشر القوات بين البلدين
ووزيره الخارجيه والدفاع اليابانيه
يجتمعان في واشنطن الامريكيين
بعد اكبر تعطل للملاحه الجويه في الولايات
المتحده منذ عقدين البيت الابيض يقول انه
لا دليل على ان الخلل نتيجته هجوم
الكتروني واداره الطيران تعمل على تحديد
الاسباب وحركه الطيران تعود تدريجيا الى
المطارات بعد الساعات من التوقف
على وقع حراك النقابيا للمطالبه بتحسين
الاوضاع المعيشيه الاتحاد التونسي للصناعه
والتجاره يقول ان الاقتصاد في خطر ويدعو
الى برنامج عاجل للانقاذ والرئيس سعيد
يلتهم اطرافا لم يسمها بالوقوف وراء نقص
مواد اساسيه في الاسواق لتاجيج الاوضاع
[موسيقى]
في هجوم انتحاري جديد عشرات القتلى
والجرحى في محيط وزاره الخارجيه الافغانيه
في كابول الوزاره تقول ان الاعداء لن
يحققوا ما سمتها اهدافهم الشريره وتنظيم
الدوله يعلن مسؤوليته
وفي لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقمين ناقشنا تسجيل
الجنيه المصري المزيد من التراجع الجرى
تداوله باكثر من 30 جنيها مقابل الدولار
الامريكي الواحد قبل ان يستقر عند حاجز 30
جنيه للدولار هذا الامر لعوامل منها رفع
البنك المركزيه المصريه اسعار الفائده في
الاونه الاخيره
وسماحوا بهبوط الجيش
شحن متزايد للدولار في البلاد وتداعيات
ذلك على حركه الاستراد
الاستطلاعي ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
طرحنا عليكم السؤال الثالث برايكم ما
مستقبل سعر صرف الجنيه المصري في ضوء
الانخفاض الحاد الحالي
نتيجه تصويتكم جاءت على النحو التاليه 20%
توقعوا انهيار مؤقتا لسعر صرف الجنيه
بينما توقعت اثنان وسبعون في المئه ان
تكون هذه بدايه لمزيد من التراجع اما
ثمانيه في المئه ثمنه الى بقاء الوضع على
ما هو عليه
هذا سؤالي يبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الذي يظهر الان على الشاشه
لقائنا على النايل سات الرقميه يتجدد
يوميا ولا تتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجدات
ومتفاعله عربيا
[موسيقى]
وفي فقره المتابعه نتناول تراجع قيمه
الجنيه المصري والنقره ما ضيفنا اسباب ذلك
وافاقه وتداعيته
[موسيقى]
في جديد يا حربي روسيا على اوكرانيا اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع في موسكو تعيين رئيس الاركان
الروسي فاليري برسم قائدا لمجموعه القوات
الروسيه في اوكرانيا كما اعلنت الوزارات
تعيين قائد القوات الجويه سيرجي سوفرنكن
وقائد القوات البريه
لقائد القوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا وقالت
الوزراء ان هذه التعييناتي في اطار رفع
مستوى قياده القوه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
وانها ترتبط بتوسيع حجم المهام وتحسين
جودتي جميع انواع الدعم وفعاليه اداره
مجموعه القوات
ميدانيا اثرت من الشباك نار لغطا بشان
الوضع في مدينه سريدارا الاستراتيجيه في
مقاطعه دونيت شرقيه اوكرانيا مالك وشركه
فاجنر
قال ان قوته حصرا سيرت سيطرت على كامل
ان القتال لا يزال مستمرا في وسط المدينه
مع بعض القوات الاوكرانيه المحاصره
الفت للنظر في هذا المشهد هو دعوه المتحدث
باسم الكرملين ديمتري بسكوفي الى عدم
التسرع في اعلان الانتصار في سوليدر
مكيه ايجابيه في تقدم القوات الروسيه لكنه
طالب بانتظار الاعلانات الرسميه
اما على الجانب الاوكراني فقد اكد الرئيس
الاوكراني ان القتال مستمر
وقال المتحدث باسم قياده عمليه المنطقه
الشرقيه في الجيش الاوكرانيين قوته تعمل
على اعاده التوازن للخطوط الدفاعيه
كوزان رئيس المركز الاوكراني للامن
والتعاون والمستشار لدى وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه بينما ينظر الينا من موسكو
اليكساندر
في الشؤون العسكريه والاستراتيجيه اهلا
بكما وابدا معك سيد ارمانوف ما الذي دفع
القياده الروسيه الى تغيير قيادتها
العسكريه في اوكرانيا في هذا الشكل وفي
هذا الوقت
انا اعتقد ان السبب هو الضروره
ضروره مرتبطه
بان الاوضاع في الجبهات الاوكرانيه تتطور
بسرعه ويجب ان يكون هناك اسلوب جديد وهذا
الاسلوب
يتشكل في الظروف التي تم تجديدها وبغض
النظر عن
التعليقات على الجنرالات
ستروكتوره
الاتهامات
وضعنا قرارات مرتبطه بما اقره السيد
الرئيس في تغيير
تشكيله الاداره العسكريه وروسيا الان تقوم
بتجهيز
الهجمات وهذا شيء يعترف به حتى العدو وحتى
تكون الاوضاع متناسبه مع المهمات الجديده
التي ستكون اكثر
فاعليه واكثر عنف يجب ان يتواجد الاشخاص
المسؤولين عن الاداره العمليه العسكريه
ولا استطيع ان اقول اتحدث باكثر من هذا
كوزان كيف تقرا هذا التغيير في هذا
التوقيت هل تراه اعتراف روسيا ربما
بالتراجع
نعم هذا هو تحديدا نحن نرى هذا
كان هناك اهداف
ووعود تم اعلانها وكان هناك وعود السيطره
على بخمه قبل راس السنه ولم يحدث والان
الكرمل لن يقوم بتحييد مجموعه ومنهم قديره
ويضعون جنارالات قديمه اي انهم يعيد
القياده العسكريه القديمه
ونحن نرى هنا ان
هناك دليل ان دراسه موف
والجنرالات الاخرى التي تعود للاداره
العسكريه
يعيدهم الكريم حتى يعيد التوازن بين
الجناح الاكثر عنفا
وبين الجناح الذي لم يقوم بتحقيق اي من
المهمات هذا يعني ان بخموت هو اوكرانيا
وان كل محاولات الهجمات من قبل الجيش
الروسي قد فشلت
عندما يقول وزير الدفاع ان هذا التبديل
جرى لان همم هناك كما قال زياده في المهام
التي يتعين انجازها وقال ايضا ان هناك
حاجه الى تفاعل اوثق مع مكونات الجيش
البارون
ان نطور النجاح الذي وصلنا له الان المحتل
الاوكراني يتراجع في جبهه ارجومسكاو
سيلدار وفي النقطتين لدينا سيطره من قبل
قوات دانيسك الجمهوريه وحتى نطور الهجمات
يجب ان يكون هناك قرارات حاده
ومسؤوله وهؤلاء الاشخاص هم المطلوبين
للقيام بهذه القرارات للاستمرار بالمعارك
ان همم
مساعد الرئيس قد قرر
بالفشل الذي
وصلوا اليه في سلندر لذلك نحن لدينا
نجاحات حتى
ارستوفي
مساعد الرئيس الاوكراني اقر بهذا
وهذا النجاح وصلنا له بفضل الاداره
الجديده
عن اداره جديده وهذا التبديل الذي يجري
حاليا كيف ينعكس على اداء القوات
الاوكرانيه وادارتها للمعركه
سيد كوزان
ساوعيد السؤال لا ادري اذا كنت سمعته
كيف ينعكس التبديل الحالي في الاداره
العسكريه روسيه على اداء الجيش الاوكراني
والقوات الاوكرانيه وادارتها للمعركه
ليس هناك اي تغيرات قد تحدث كما اننا كنا
ننجح بجميع المهمات
كما ان الاداره العسكريه الروسيه القديمه
لم تكن تنجح باي اهداف حتى هذه التشكيله
التي هي اصلا بدات في العمليه العسكريه
وهمم استروفكن هو من بدا بالعمليه
العسكريه وراينا انهم فشلوا في الخريف
وبعد ان تم تبديلهم من قبل الرئيس بوتين
الان بوتين يعيدهم لان
ااه لان التبديل همم
لم يعد هناك احد جدد يقوم بتبديلهم بهم
لذلك
ليس هناك همم سبب يجعلنا نقلق لان سرفيكين
هو المدير القديم للعمليات العسكريه التي
فشلت
وكانوا
يعلنوا عن هذا
بقناواتهم
والاداره التي تعود الان همم وتقوم باداره
القوات البريه الروسيه همم كانوا
قد كذبوا على اداراتهم العسكريه
والدعوا النجاح وهم كانوا يفشلوا والان هم
مضطرون ان يقوموا بحم مسؤوليات اعمالهم
واقوالهم
شكرا جزيلا لك السر هيكزان رئيس المركز
الاوكراني للامن والتعاون والاستشار لدى
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه من كيف اشكرك
واشكر ايضا ضيفي من موسكو اليكساندر
العسكريه والاستراتيجيه
الان الى سطح الاحداث اذا يطفو اسم فاجنر
الذي توصف وهذه الشركه التي توصف بالشركه
العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه لكنها متهمه
بكونها الغطاء الذي تمارس من خلاله روسيا
تمارسها نفودها في اكثر من بؤره صراع
ومنطقتي نزاع على اوكرانيا ابرزوا مثال
على ذلك
في ظل تقدم روسيا في هذه الاخيره لكن
بالارتكاز عالمي للشيعه فاجنر فيبرز
مالكها
برفقه مقاتلين داخل احد انفاق مناجم الملح
في سوريا ليعلن سيطره قوته حصرا على كامل
المدينه توصف فاجنر بانها شركه عسكريه
خاصه ويراها اخرون اقرب ما تكون الى
مجموعه روسيه عسكريه شبه رسميه فهي واحده
تتمتع وفقا صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
بالاستقلاليه وتتبع وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
يعتقد ان مؤسسها
ضابط سابقا في القوه الخاصه وحملت اسمه
السري فاجنر لكنها الان مملوكه لرجل
الاعمال
ويعرف باسم طباخ بوتين لاداته شركه
كونكورد المنظمه لحفظه الاستقبال
بالكريملاند وتضم مزيجا من مقاتلنا يقدمون
خدمتهم مقابل المال بداته لاول مره مع ضم
روسيا لشبه جزيره القرم في عام 2014
ونفذتها هجمات في شرق اوكرانيا يقول
مسؤولون بريطانيون ان عدد مقاتل فاجنر
ارتفع من نحو الفا الى ما يقرب من 20,000
مقاتل في اوكرانيا
من اجمالي القوه الروسيه على الارض افتتح
بريكوجين اول مقر ليفاجنر في مدينه سان
بطرسبورغ الروسيه وقال في بيانه مهمته
مركز فاجنر هي توفير بيئه مريحه لتوليد
افكار جديده مغريه تحسين القدره الدفاعيه
لروسيا
وتحسين القدره دفاعيه لروسيا لا يمكنه
اخفاء حقيقه الاتهامات لبابنار بارسال
مسلحها الى عده دول في امريكا اللاتينيه
وافريقيا وتنفيذ ما توصف بالعمليه القذره
في مناطق النزاعات المختلفه ففي سوريا
انتشرت فاجنر لدعم النظام السوري منذ 2016
خصوصا حول حقول النفط في دير الزور وخطفت
الاضواء اكثر بعد مقتل اعاده من افرادها
في غاره امريكيه عام 2018
وتنشط المجموعه في ليبيا منذ 2016 وتدعم
القوات المواليه للواء المتقاعد خليفه
حفتر وكشف تقرير سري للامم المتحده بوجود
اكثر من 1000 من عناصرها لكن التقرير اخرى
تقدرهم بالالاف كما تنتشر ميليشيا فاكنار
في جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى لحراسه مناجم
الذهب والالماس وتشير تقارير الى وجود
الله في مدغشقر وموزمبيق والسودان وكان
اخر انتشار لها في مالي بعد انسحاب القوه
الفرنسيه من هناك
[موسيقى]
والان الى ملف التوتر في شرقي اسيا اذا
استبق رئيس وزراء الياباني
للولايات المتحده بالتحذير من تكرار
الاوكرانيتها العسكريه بما يجعلها صاحبه
الثالث اكبر الميزانيه عسكريه في العالم
بعد الولايات المتحده والصين بحلول عام
انا بيئه الامن في العالم تمر بتغيير كبير
وانا ما يحدث في اوكرانيا اليوم قد تشهده
اسيا غدا
كانت بريطانيا واليابان وقعتات اتفاقيه
دفاعيه هي الابرز بين البلدين في مئه
وعشرين عاما
اتفاقيه الوصول المتبادل التي وقعها في
لندن رئيسه حكومتي البلدين
بين الجانبين والسماح بنشر قوات كل منهما
على اراضي الاخر وذلك في اطار تعميق تعاون
قوتهما ياتي توقيع هذه الاتفاقيه بعد
اسابيع معدوده من بدء تعاون المملكه
المتحده واليابان وايطاليا في مجال تطوير
الجيل التالي من الطائره الجويه القتاليه
اضافه الى الشراكه الرقميه الجديده بين
بريطانيا
الشهر الماضي لتعزيز تعاون في المجال
السبراني ومجالي اشباه الموصلات
تاتي جوله رئيس الوزراء الياباني هذا بعد
نحوي ثلاثه اسابيع من اجراء اليابان اكبر
تعديل على سياستها الدفاعيه منذ نهايه
الحرب العالميه الثانيه واقرارها وثيقه
سياسيه دفاعيه جديده
تعتبروا الصين تحديا استراتيجيا
يتضمن هذا التحول المضاعفه ميزانيه الدفاع
السنويه اضافه الى توحيد قيادتها العسكريه
وزياده مدى صواريخها في حين تعد القدره
على شان هجوم مضاد واستهداف المواقع
اطلاقه صواريخ العدو من ابرز معالم
التغيير في العقيده القتاليه اليابانيه
وفي سياق نفسه قالت صحيفه الوصف الجنرال
ان الاداره الامريكيه توسع دائره
الالتزامها الامني تجاه اليابان ونقلت
الصحيفه عن مسؤولين امريكيين انا الخطه
الامريكيه تشمل تمركز فوج ساحليا للبحريه
الامريكيه بحلول عام 2025 في اي قنوات بعد
افراد او بعدد افراد يصل الى 2200 فرد
مزودين بصواريخ مضاده للسفن
وقت عيد قرار
الحصول على صواريخ كروز الامريكيه من طراز
توماهوك بما يمكنها من ضرب اهداف في البر
الرئيسي الصيني وفي كوريا الشماليه في
حاله حدوث اي عدوان
بحسب الصحيفه
[موسيقى]
استونيت حركه الملاحه الجويه تدريجيا في
انحاء الولايات المتحده بعد ساعات من
التوقف بسبب عطل في حواسيب وكاله الطيران
الفيدراليه تجاوز عدد رحله الملغاه الف
رحله والمتاخره اكثر من سته الاف
اداره الطيران الفيدراليه قالت ان خللا
اصاب نظام اشعار الرحلات الجويه ما دفعها
الى تعليق جميع الرحلات المحليه في
الولايات المتحده قرار تعليق الملاحه
الجويه اجبل شركات الطيران الامريكيه على
تاخير الاف الرحلات الجويه فضلا عن الغاء
اخرى
وعن سبب العطل الذي ادى الى اصابه حركه
الطيران بشلل في الولايات المتحده لساعات
استبعد البيت الابيض فرضيه الهجوم
السيبراني واوضح ان الرئيس جوبيد امر بفتح
تحقيق
تحدثت للتو مع وزير النقل ولا يعرفون بعد
سبب العطل لكنني كنت معهم عبر الهاتف
وطالبتهم بابلاغي فور الكشف عن السبب نظام
اشعار الرحلات الجويه التي اصابه العطل
مخصصه لابلاغ الطيران بحالات الطوارئ
وبمعلومات تتعلق بسلامه عمليات الملاحه
الجويه
ووفقه اداره طيران الفيدراليه تعرض نظام
الاشعار لعطل فني خلال ساعات الليل قبل ان
يعود الى العمل عند الساعه 9:00 صباحا
بتوقيت الساحل الشرقي الامريكي ليسمح
باستئناف الرحلات الجويه تدريجيا
التاكد من سلامه الطائرات ولهذا السبب
لجئنا الى هذا القرار المتطرف والضروري
بوقف الرحلات لكن الان وبعد عوده الامور
الى طبيعتها اولويه القصوى وهي معرفه
اسباب ما حصل وكيف يمكن الامور ان تصل الى
هذا المستوى من التراب والتاكد عدم تكرار
ذلك تعطل حركه الطائرات المدنيه المحليه
في الولايات المتحده يثير تساؤلات عن
سلامه وكفاءه الانظمه الفيدراليه المعنيه
بتنظيم الملاحه الجويه في ظل تعهد
الكونجرس بالتحقيق في الاسباب فدي منصور
الجزيره من امام مطار ريجن في العاصمه
واشنطن
خبير الطيران وعضو فريق السلامه في اداره
الطيران الفيدراليه سابقا اهلا وسهلا بك
سيد بيلي في الواقع ما حدث اليوم ما درجه
خطورته بالنسبه للولايات المتحده وبالنسبه
للمتابعين حول العالم همم بصور مختلفه
طب امواج
لم يكن فقط ازعاج لكن كان قضيه امنيه
وكاله الطيران الفدراليه ادركت ان كان
هنالك خلل واوقفت النظام لم تكن كنا كان
هنالك خطر على السلامه لكن هذا التعطل
وغير
متوقع سبب اضطرابا لسفر الالاف من من
الناس
من المسافرين ولكن هل يلفتك شيء عن يعني
هل هناك شيء غامض في الموضوع التحقيقات ما
زالت جاريه البيت الابيض يستبعد همم
اختراق سبراني او هجوم سبراني هل تتفق مع
هذا الاستبعاد
تعرفون هم يعرفون التفاصيل خلف الكواليس
انها ليس لدي تلك
المعلومات شعرت ان ان ما علمت بهذا الحادث
انه لم يكن حادثه سيبرانيا لا اعتقد ان
هذا النظام بالذات
ربما تم قرصنته من قبل
قراصنه هنالك اعتقد انه هنالك
اكبر خطرت لي الفكره لكنني لم اكن اميل
نحو فكره
الهجمه
السيبراني هم يقومون وكاله الطيران
الفيدراليه هم يقومون بعمل جيد في مساله
همم تبادل المعلومات والتحقيق وانظمه
التشغيل ليس امرا جديده
ممكن ان يكون له تاثير على اي عمليات
عسكريه تقوم بها الولايات المتحده بسبب
هذا الخلق
انا
يؤثر اي عمليه عسكريه اللاعب الجيش يمتلك
طائرات الخاصه وايضا هذا النظام يؤثر على
شركات الطيران وعلى الطائرات الخاصه
بالتالي الطائرات التي
كلما عدا الطيران الطائرات العسكريه تم
ايقافه لكن الاجابه على السؤال لم تكن
قضيه
السلامه لان وكاله الطيران الفيدراليه
اتخذت القرار
الصحيح وقاموا بتجميد كل عمل طائرات قد
يؤثر على الطائره التي قبل الاقلاع بمعنى
انه اذا ما كنت انا طيار سيقوم تفحص هذا
النظام قبل
عمليه الاقلاع لكن اذا ما كانت الطائرات
في الجو وكانت هذه المعلومات غير متوفره
قد يتم تلقينها للطاء طيار عن كابتن
الطائره بشكل شفوي من قبل برج المراقبه
شكرا جزيلا لك خبير الطيران
بيليه عضو فريق السلامه في اداره الطيران
الفرديه سابقا شكرا لك وما زلنا في انتظار
اذا همم نتائج التحقيق لنعرف بالضبط
[موسيقى]
حضر الاتحاد التونسي للصناعه والتجاره من
ان اقتصاد البلاد في خطر مشيرا الى ان
الحله يكمن في برنامج عاجل للانقاذ ومن
جانبه جدد الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد
اتهامته لاطراف لم يسميها بالوقوف في وراء
نقص عدد من المواد الاساسيه في الاسواق في
الوقت نفسه لا يزال الجدل مهتدما بشان
مساله استقلال السلطه القضائيه
الدفاع عن القضاه المعزولين العياش
الهمامي امام القضاء بتهمه نشر شائعه
كاذبه نتابع تقرير ماجد عبد الهادي
لا قوه تعلو على قوه راس الدوله او حتى
توازيها مكانتانا ولا نص دستوريا يردعه عن
فعل ما يحدث في عينيه لقمع معارضيه وتوسيع
نفوثه وسيطرته على السلطات الاخرى
التنفيذيه والتشريعيه والقضائيه التي
تعارفت المجتمعات الحديثه على اعتبار
الفصل في ما بينها اهم اسس لعبه
الديمقراطيه
ذاك ايجاز طالما صحفي وسط استبداد كثير من
الزعماء العرب على مدار عقود سبقه انفجار
ربيع العربي بدءا من تونس قبل 12
في تونس نفسها عاقبا انتصار ثوره الياسمين
بان الحلقه تغيرت لان اعلان الرئيس
التونسي الاسبق زين العابدين بن علي تفهمه
لغضب شعبه بعد فوات الاوان قد بدا منذ اذن
درسا للمستبدين عموما ولمن سيخلفه في حكمه
بلاده على نحو الخاص كلامكم اليوم
ونكلمكم الكل
في تونس وخرج تونس ستجري مياه كثيره تحت
الجسر وسيتعاقب على حكم تونس ثلاثه رؤساء
اخرين قبل ان تؤول مقاليد السلطه الى
الرئيس الحالي قيس سعيد الذي يتهمه
معارضوه بالانقلاب على الديمقراطيه والسعي
الى احياء الاستبداد في مقابل قوله
المتكرر انه يحاول انقاذ البلاد من الشلل
السياسي وواعيده المستمر بالانتصار على من
يصفهم بالخونه والعملاء من
المعركه التي شهدت على مدى 18 الشهران
اتخاذ قرارات واجراءات رئاسيه لتعزيز
هيمنه سعيد على السلطات التنفيذيه
والتشريعيه والقضائيه مازالت تتوالى فصول
وجديدها مثل المحامي العياشي الهمامي منسق
هيئه الدفاع عن القضاه المعزولين امام
قاضي التحقيق بتهمه ترويجي ونشر شائعه
كامله
مع المختلفين عنهم في الراي وهي سياسه
العصا الغليظه والاحاله على القضاء وبث
الرعب والتخفيف وكان الهمام الذي شغل من
قبل منصب وزير حقوق الانسان قد اتهم وزيره
العدل بالامتناع عن تنفيذ احكام قضائيه
تنص على اعاده قضاه معزوله الى وظائفهم
تنفيذ الاحكام فقط
قلت لهم ملفات ووجهت لهم هم وليس هذا
الحدث الا مجرد تفصيل في الازمه التونسيه
لكن اهميته تكمل ربما في انه يعكس الخلافه
بين رؤيتين تقوم احداهما وهي المعارضه على
اعتبار القضاء سلطه مستقله بينما تقوم
الثانيه التي يتبناها الرئيس سعيد على
اعتباره مجرد وظيفه
وثمه في السياق مسلسل خطوات رئاسيه وجهت
بمعارضه قطاعات واسعه من الطيف السياسي
والاجتماعي ابرزها حل مجلس النواب وحل
المجلس الاعلى للقضاء وصياغه واقرار دستور
جديد للبلاد من دون التشاور مع القوى
الفاعله ثم اجراء انتخابات تشريعيه لم
يشارك فيها سوى من نسبته احد 10 وربع في
المئه من الناخبين
ما عندهاش فشقاباويه
اذا يزداد تعقيدا وفي التعليق عليه يلاحظ
مراقبون من ابناء البلاد كيف يستعيد كثيرا
معارضي الرئيس الاسبق زين العابدين بن علي
سيرتهم الاولى عبر تحركات احتجاجيه ضد
سياسات الرئيس الحاليه قيس سعيد وطبعا
وسطت عقيدا اضافييه تشكله الازمه
الاقتصاديه المستعصيه واخر مظاهرها جحا في
المواد التموينيه الاساسيه
وعلاجته احدى وسائل الاعلام الرسميه بدعوه
الناس الى الامتناع عن تناول الحليب لانه
مضر بصحه الكبار
وينضم الان الينا من تونس بالحسنه ليحياوي
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا وسهلا بك
استاذ حسن اذا
كما ذكر التقرير المشهد معقد جدا في تونس
ياسين واقتصاديا استدعاء حقوقي مثل
العياشي الهمامي في هذا الوقت الا يزيد
الامور تعقيدا
كذلك
[موسيقى]
التي تتعلق بمحاكمه
احد متن الحديث الذي تفضل به العيش
الامامي هل هو فعلا نشر اخبار كاذبه او هو
مجرد قراءه واو تحليل بوضع سياسي واقتصادي
والاجتماعي يختلف الجميع في قراءه مفرداته
او غير ذلك الحدث اصبح حدثا بعد ان رفعت
قضيه بالعيش الامامي ودفع العيش الهناني
امام القضاء وهنا حقيقه تمت سؤال حقيقي هل
ان من يعملون في دائره الرئيس السيسي صحيح
[موسيقى]
ليس على درايه وليس له اي يعني الراي فيما
يفعله المحيطون به
لا الامر ليس كذلك الامر طبعا انه لديه
درايه ولديه معرفه ولكن بعض
الاصيل توجد في محيط الرئيس سعيد والتي
تعمل مع رئيس مجلس صعيد تضره من حيث تريد
ان تقدم له خدماته وليست في حاجه اليه
اعتقد ان الجميع يعلم الان بمحاكمه العيش
الهجماني وتقريبا اكثر من 90% منهم اجزم
انهم لا يعلمون اساسا ماذا قال العيش
الهمامي واذا كان ما قاله العيش الامامي
له اي تاثير كان وبالمناسبه هي ليست هذه
الحادثه الاولى هناك الكثير من الحوادث
والتي تدل وبصوره غريبه ان الكثيرون
من الحوادث بمعنى ان هناك مسار الرئيس قصص
سعيد يسر عليه مسار همم لا يقضي باستشاره
اطراف مختلفه فاعله همم مسار يتلقى معارضه
كبيره من الداخل من اطراف مختلفه وايضا
انتقادات من الخارج ما السبب اذن في تمسك
بهذا المسار
هو اساسا الرئيس
الى حد هذه اللحظه وبعد سنه ونص تقريبا لم
نرى اجراءات استثنائيه ولم نتعرف على شخوص
استثنائيين وبالتالي اذا كان الرئيس سعيد
يريد ان ينهي هذا المسار الذي اعلنه ويخلق
حاله الاستثناء فان تغيير بعض العناصر
المحيطه به بل وبعض الافراد الموجودين في
الحكومه امر ضروري تماما اولا لانها هذه
العناصر لم يرتدي
الاستثناء وثانيا لان الكثير منهم يبدو
انهم يعملون جلد مصلحه رئيس الجمهوريه
نبقى في تونس ونظم الينا الان العياشي
الهماميه منسق هيئه الدفاع عن القضاه
المعفيين ووزير حقوق الانسان التونسي
السابق اهلا بك معنا اذا اولا اريد ان
اسمع قراءتك انت ل همم الطريقه التي تم
فيها استدعائك والطريقه التي تم فيها
التحقيق معك تفضل
شكرا
اجريت حوار في اذاعه تونسيه خاصه همم
تحدثت فيها بصفه محامي القضاه المعفيين عن
المظلم التي تعرضوا لها وكشفت كيف ان
وزيره العدل قد يعني كونت ملفات من همم
الخواء في تونس نقول فبركه ملفات ضد هؤلاء
القدام بعد ان حصل على حكما من المحكمه
الاداريها يقلي بايقاف تنفيذ امر عزهم من
رئيس الجمهوريه ويرجعهم الى العمل ولكنها
رفضت وبهذا فهي ترتكب جريمه قالوا لي يعني
منسوس عليها في القانون تسمى عن بناء
جريمه عدم تنفيذ قرارات قضائيه نفسها
ويعاقب عليها القانون وهذا ما يعني اخرجها
من
همم معناها اخرجها من المعقول العادي
وقررت اا فجاه يوم الجمعه ان تكون لي ملف
يحتوي على تهم اعتمدت فيه على مرسوم وفي
تونس يعني قانون استغله رئيس الجمهوريه
يعاقب ب 10 سنوات
او ينسب خبر غير حقيقي الى شبه موظف وفي
هذه الحاله اعتبرت ان كلامي هو اشاعات
ونشر اخبار غير حقيقيه
وتكون الملف في ظرف يعني 10 ساعات من يوم
الجمعه صباحا همم بدات الاجراءات ووصل
الملف الى مكتب هذه التحقيق يوم الجمعه
مساءا او تعيا بالتحقيق في ذلك اليوم واا
يوم الاثنين اصبح لملف المنشور همم الواقع
انا متمسك ومعيد عديد من احرار تونس انا
هذا النظام لانه فشل في الاجابه عن مشاكل
المجتمع ومشاكل البلاد
وتعسف على اعاده قطاعات ومنها القضاء لم
يعد له من اجابه الى العصاء الغليظه
والاحاله على المحاكم وتلفيق التهم
وترويع المواطنين بهذه المراسيم التي
تحتوي على عقوبات كوبرا حتى الناس
الرئيس سعيد ليس بالضبط او ليس بالضروره
من يقوم بهذه الاجراءات انما هناك مجموعه
حول وان على الرئيس ان يتخلى عنهم المسؤول
ما تعليقك على هذه النقطه كما قال ضيفنا
قبل قليل على حسب
معناها نريد من المواطنين ان يقبلوا ان
رئيس الجمهوريه لا علم له بما يحيط وانه
يعني له مستشارين لا ينصحونه كما يجب في
هذه الحاله عليه ان يرحل له هو لانه لم
يحصل اختيار مستشارين لا لان نبحث عن
هؤلاء مستشارين يعني همم الاسماء غير
المعروفه غير ذلك وان يريد منه ان يبعدهم
عنها هذا رئيس ليس له الكفاءه في اداره
دوله وقد اثبت ذلك وكل العالم اصبح اليوم
يعرف ان تونس
في جميع المجالات بصفه خطيره منذ وصوله
الى الحق لا يعني ذلك ان تونس قبل ذلك كان
في بحبوحه من العيش بالعكس كان هناك ازمه
عميقه على كل المستويات وهذا ما همم همم
سهل له
الاستلاه على الدوله يوم 25 الماضيه
جويليه 2021 ولكن بعد ذلك زاد الوضع سوءا
واليوم لم يعد نظام الحكم فقط مهددا اصبحت
اسس الدوله بنفسها مهدده فبعد ان الغي
الثلث في في كما هي موجوده في كل دوله
الديمقراطيه
واعادها الى مرتبه الوظيفه وقاعده انه لا
توجد
مضيفه اصبح اليوم همم يعني همم
اشخاص تجاوزوا القانون وان هناك جماعات هي
من تقف وراء كل هذه الفوضى التي تحدث في
البلاد الان همم كيف يبدو مستقبل همم
المشهد الحقيقي في ظل هذه التصريحات وفي
ظل ما يتم اتخاذه بحق الشخصيات معروفه
المشهد الحقوقي سيء جدا خاصه بعد اصداره
لهذا الموسم الذي كنت اتحدث عنها هو الذي
يقرر عقوبات كبرى لمن يعبر على راي
المختلف لرئيس الدوله بدعوه انه نسى امور
غير حقيقيه او اصدرها اشاعات ولكن ليس
الوضع الحقوق فقط فالحقوقيونهم بطبيعتهم
مناضلون ويتحملون مسؤوليه اختياراتهم
وقادمون ونحن قادمون على
يعني السعوديه ولكن جميع
قطاعات المجتمع تشتكي اليوم يعني هناك
البطاله وانعدام وجود الاسئله او المواد
الاساسيه وهناك التضخم المالي الكبير الى
غير ذلك من المشاكل والتي اثبت عجزه عنها
ولذلك نحن ندعو الى جمعه يوم السبت القادم
يوم 14 عيد ثوره تجمع بشارع الثوره لكي
نقول له في هذا المسار التدميري اشكرك
العياشي الهماميه من تونس شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
ادى تفجير بالقرب من وزاره الخارجيه
الافغانيه في العاصمه كابول الى مقتل 21
شخصا واصابه 34
وقلبيان للخارجيه الافغانيه ان الاعداء لن
يتمكنوا من تحقيق اهدافها مع عبر اعمالهم
الشريره على حد تعبيره واعلن تنظيم الدوله
مسؤوليته عن الهجوم الانتحاري
تفجير ببصمه تنظيم الدوله ولايه خرسان
الهدف هذه المره بالقرب من وزاره الخارجيه
والرساله الملطخه بدم القتل والجرحى لمن
في كابول وخارج افغانستان الضحيه كلهم من
موظفين الوزاره
الهجمات الانتحاريه في البلاد بالرغم من
الغارات التي تشمها قوه الامن ضد مسلحيه
تنظيم المعادي لحكومه الطالبان دشنت
افغانستان اول يوم من السنه الجديده
بالتفجير نفذها انتحاري على الدراجه
الناريه امام المطار العسكري بالعاصمه لا
يبعد المطار سواء 400 متر عن مقر وزاره
الداخليه سقط فيه 10 القتلى والجرحى
ديسمبر الماضي كان مؤلما على ضحايا هجوم
مسلح على فندق يرتاده الصينيون الصادمه
لبيدين قالت قوه الامن الافغانيه حينها
انها قتلت ثلاثه من المهاجمين على تنظيم
الدوله في ولايه خرسان مسئوليته عن
الاعتداء تنظيم يصف التوسع الاقتصادي
العالمي لبيج بالامبرياليه الصينيه ويرفع
سقف تهديداته بعد كل تقارب بين حكومتي
كابول وبيجين استقبلت افغانستان في مارس
العام الماضي وزير الخارجيه الصيني في
زياره هي الاولى منذ عوده طالبان الى
الحكم وحبله بالرسائل الاقليميه والدوليه
الصوره لمصلحه حكومه تعاني عزلتا وعقوبات
دوليه تقودها الولايات المتحده وبالنسبه
لبيدين فهي جوله لكسب مزيد من النقاط ضد
واشنطن ومشروعها الفاشل على مدى 20 عاما
في بلاد الافغان
ببراغماتيه تتعامل الصين مع حكومه لا
تعترف بها رسميا ولكن تصر على العلاقات
والديه معها عنوانها المعلن المساعده في
اعاده بناء افغانستان من بعض تفاصيلها
تامين استثمارات جديده
فضحت الروح في مشاريع متوقفه مثل السئف
العمليات في منجم بولايه لوجر تكرار هجمات
التنظيم الدوله بدعم من ولمصلحه من قائمه
مخاوف الافغان وعمومهم تطول عقوبه دوليه
وانتقام التنظيم المتشدد لا تجف دماء
تفجير حتى ينفذ الذي بعدها
مراسلنا ناصر شديد ناصر هرشا شيء جديد عن
هذا الانفجار
اخر شيء همم ليلى ان تنظيم الدوله هو من
اعلن مسؤوليته عن هذا التفجير طبعا كان
هناك اختراق امني كبير
للدخول من هذا الشارع المغلق في الاساس
للمره وكل من يدخل ان كان بيته قريبا ولا
يستطيع الدخول الا من هذا الشارع يتم
تفتيشه ذاتيا بالاضافه الى وجود اجهزه
للكشف عن المعادن كيف دخل هذا الانتحاري
وفجر نفسه امام
البوابه الرئيسيه
لوزاره الخارجيه هذا الامر يعني تطرح على
الحكومه الافغانيه والقوات الامنيه التي
قتل منها ثلاثه اشخاص همم بالاضافه الى
طبعا اغلب القتلى كانوا ممن يعملون في
وزاره الخارجيه بالقرب من هذا ال- ال- ال-
المبنى مبنى وزاره الخارجيه هناك ايضا
السفاره الصينيه وهذا الامر لربما يكون
لديه يعني رسائل محدده معينه
للتقارب الصيني الافغاني خاصه بعد توقيع
اتفاقيه بين شركه رئيسيه صينيه للنفط
للتنقيب على النفط في افغانستان وهذا
الامر يضع علامات كبيره امامها الحكومه
الافغانيه التي وعدت منذ وصولها بانها
ستقضي على اي تنظيم ان كان تنظيم الدوله
او حتى
يعني فريق مسلح او تشكيل مسلح وهنا
المقصود المقاومه الشماليه التي ايضا
هاجمت القوات الحكوميه في شمال العاصمه
كابل او مدن الشماليه نعم نعم
[موسيقى]
اذا نعود الان الى تراجع اسعار الجنيه
المصري فقد عرفت البلاد ساعات من الاثاره
والترقب شغلت الاسواق المصريه والمصريين
عموما مع رصد تقلبات سعر صرف الجنيه
المصري مقابل الدولار خلال التداولات
الصباحيه تجاوز سعر صرف الدولار الامريكي
حاجز ال 30 جنيها وذلك لاول مره في تاريخ
العمله المصريه
في الحكوميه تراجع سعر صرف الجنيه بالنسبه
مقارنه بما قبل بدايه الازمه الاخيره وتم
تداوله بسعر وصل الى نحو 32 جنيها مقابل
الدولار
وبعد تعاملات متقلبه وصلت بالدولار الى 32
جنيها تحسنت قيمه الجنيه وارتفعت الى نحو
30 جنيه مقابل الدولار وهو ما يمثل نسبه
تراجع بنحو 91% مصر تعاني ازمه حاده في
النقد الاجنبي
تراجع احتياطيها منه الى 34
مليار دولار مقابل واحد واربعين مليار في
شباط فبراير
هذا الاحتياطي يشمل ثمانيه وعشرين مليار
دولار او دعتها دول عده في الاشهر الاخيره
لدى البنك المركزي المصري ونحن نستعرض هذه
الارقام يطرح السؤال نفسه
ما الذي يعنيه خفض قيمه العمله المصريه
المره الثالثه في 10 اشهر استجابه لصندوق
النقد الدولي
اسير مباشر
وغير مسبوقه
على القدره الشرائيه لملايين الاسر في مصر
البلد العربي الاكبر ديموغرافيه والذي
يبلغ عدد سكانه مئه واربعه ملايين
في بلد يستورد غالبيه احتياجاته تنعكس كل
زياده في سعر الدولار فورا على اسعار
السلع وهذمات تدل عليه ارقام رسميه صدرت
امس فقط
يقول البنك المركزي المصري الى معدل
التضخم الاساسي ارتفع الشهر الماضي الى
نحو اربعه 24 فصل خمسه على اساسين سنوي
وبدوره ارجع الجهاز المركزي للتعبئه
والاحصاء وهو الجهه الرسميه ارجع هذه
الزياده الى
التضخم معدل التضخم الى ارتفاع اسعار
الطعام والمشروبات بنسبه 38%
في مؤتمر صحفيا اوضحت رئيسه بعثه صندوق
النقد الدولي في مصر ابانوب ان التضخم لن
يبدا في التراجع الا بحلول عام او منتصف
عام 2024
ليه مناقشه كل هذه النقاط ينضم الينا من
انتاريو في كندا مصطفى يوسف الباحث في
الاقتصاد السياسي ومدير المركز الدولي
للدراسات التنمويه
والاستراتيجيه اهلا وسهلا بك استاذ مصطفى
ربما لمن يتابع الازمه النقديه في مصر
ربما هذا التراجع القياسي في سعر الجنيه
قد لا يكون مفاجئا له تماما
هل توافق
يعني منذ ان بدات الجمهوريه الجديده في
يوليو 2013 كان سعر صرف الجنيه المصري
امام الدولار
خمسه اضعاف يعني
[موسيقى]
حيث ان الجمهوريه الجديده لم تاخذ في
الحسبان اي خطط تنمويه وكان يعني النموذج
كان
الاقتراض ثم بيعوا الوصول ثم يعني مزيد من
فرض الدروس الضرائب والرسوم
واتباع يعني
صندوق النقد الدوليه التي لم تنجح اطلاقا
يعني ادت لكوارث في الارجنتين في تشيلي في
البرازيل يعني من ساره بعكس مواصفات
الصندوق مثل تجربه ماليزيا مهير محمد
تجربه البرازيل يعني الولد الذي الاولى
الاولى
جيده للغايه نحن امام اقتصاد تفضلي اليك
استاذ يوسف يعني التفسيرات كثيره وضعت
لذلك منها الحرب الاوكرانيه منها الاداء
الاقتصادي الحكومي او البحث عن نظام اكثر
مرونه الان يعني وسط كل هذه التفسير هل هل
فعلا الامر يعني حصل في هذا ام هو اعمى من
هذا
الامر
2021 قبل ان تبدا هذه الحرب 22 كان رصيد
البنوك المصريه بالسالب سبعه مليار دولار
رصيد العمله الاجنبيه بالسالب فالامر يعني
يرجع في المقام الاول الى يعني الاقتراض
الى حساب وينتقل هذه القروض بدلا من ان
تشجع يعني الحكومه الصناعات الصغيره
والمتجهات الصغار والاستثمار في التعليم
وفي الانسان كان الاستثمار في الحجر
والطرق والبنايات الفارهه والعاصمه
الجديده وتوسعه قناه السويس وفي امور كل
الخبراء في العالم يعني تحدثوا عنها انا
قرات يعني تقرير
البروفيشنال كنز همم يعني البنك يعني
المؤشرات في مصر البنك المركزي الجهاز
المركزي للتعرف على الاحصائيه كل التضخم
24 ونصف في المئه
يقول انه 85% نحن امام كارثه حقيقيه يعني
في 2016 مع التعويم الاول
اسفه اسفه جدا لمقاطعتك ولكن هذا كل ما
يسمح به الوقت استاذ مصطفى يوسف البحث في
الاقتصاد السياسي ومدير المركز الدولي
للدراسات التنمويه والاستراتيجيه شكرا لك
من انتاريو
[موسيقى]
ما حدث في الولايات المتحده اليوم يذكرونا
بتداعيات ما قد يترتب على عطل تقنيا هنا
او هناك من تاثير على حياتنا اليوميه فقد
تابعنا جميعا قبل الساعات كيف تسبب عطل
تقني في اجباري هيئه الطيران المدني
الامريكيه على تعليق كل الرحلات الداخليه
المغادره من الولايات المتحده مؤقتا ثم
تاخرت سته الاف رحله جويه في الولايات
المتحده عن الاقلاب تم تجاوز الخلل واقلعت
الرحلات تدريجيا في وقت لاحق لكن السؤال
يبقى كيف يمكن التاكد من عدم تكرار مثل
هذه الابطال وما السبيل الى تاميني نظامي
نقل جوليا وهل تسهل التكنولوجيا وتطورها
المذهل حياه الناس
تعقد الامور اكثر في بعض الاحيان سؤال
[موسيقى]